mes chers compatriotes le moment est
venu de décider
la campagne est finie demain vous allez
élire celui qui pendant sept ans va
conduire notre pays et c'est capital
si vous avez approuvé la façon dont le
candidat du parti socialiste lorsqu'ils
gouvernaient la france avec les pleins
pouvoirs de 81 à 86 à diriger nos
affaires à leur apporte lui votre
soutien si au contraire vous avez
approuvé l'oeuvre de redressement
difficiles que j'ai engagées depuis deux
ans avec mon gouvernement appuyé sur ma
majorité
alors je vous demande de soutenir mon
action
mais en tous les cas ne vous abstenez
pas ce n'est pas un comportement
responsable dans la démocratie et
s'abstenir dimanche c'est voter en
réalité pour le candidat socialiste
depuis deux ans j'ai gouverner notre
pays je les fais en harmonie parfaite
avec les autres pays de la communauté
européenne
dans le même esprit je les fais jusqu'au
terme de mon mandat comme vous avez pu
le voir avec les initiatives que j'ai
pris pour rétablir le respect de la
démocratie de la liberté et lutter
contre le terrorisme en nouvelle
calédonie ou en ayant permis la
libération de nos derniers otages
cette action
je veux la continuer et l'amplifier
pourquoi pour avoir demain une france
plus solidaire d'où mon projet à la fois
de maintenir et de renforcer notre
sécurité sociale à l'égard de tous et
notamment des plus âgés mais aussi pour
une nouvelle conquête sociale
bon j'ai beaucoup parlé celle de
l'activité minimum garanti je veux aussi
une france qui prépare mieux son avenir
par une éducation une formation de ses
enfants
moderniser et meilleure part des
entreprises qui investissent une
meilleure recherche parce que c'est ça
l'emploi de demain aussi un par une
france qui s'intègre avec dynamisme dans
l'europe l'europe est une grande chance
pour nous c'est un défi que nous devons
relever mais cela exige que nous
défendions avec beaucoup de fermeté
comme je lé fais depuis deux ans comme
ce n'était pas le cas avant les intérêts
des français
les industriels des commerçants des
artisans et professions libérales de nos
paysans ses intérêts qui dans le cadre
des grandes négociations avant
l'ouverture du grand marché unique
européen doivent être avec compétence et
ténacité défendu et croyez moi
de ce point de vue vous pouvez me faire
confiance voilà notre ambition elle
suppose le rassemblement de nos énergies
de toutes celles et de tous ceux qui
veulent mettre leur dynamisme leur foi
dans l'avenir de notre pays au service
de l'ensemble des français au service de
notre nation de notre patrie
c'est ce que je vous propose et si je
vous dis que vous pouvez me faire
confiance pour défendre cette action je
sais qu'au fond de vous même
en raison de cet amour partagé qui est
le nôtre pour la france
vous approuvez ces grandes intentions
ensemble faisons cela et c'est pourquoi
dimanche
je vous fais confiance